often do I need to do coffee enemas because we recommend a people that don't have cancer to do coffee
enemas. Certainly we recommend people that have cancer to do coffee enemas, but it can be beneficial
for people with any type of chronic disease. So what's the benefit of doing coffee enemas is really to
simulate liver detox pathways and doing so by stimulating the parasympathetic nervous system. So remember,
autonomic nervous system is your automatic nervous system and it controls basically all your
functions and everything in your body. So all your organs are controlled by your autonomic nervous system
and you don't have to think about it. You don't have to think about your liver, liver,
inner, your kidney, kidney. You don't have to know what it does, right? So those functions take
place because of deep, deep part of your brain communicating through your cranial nerves to your
organs to tell those organs what to do. That's part of your automatic or autonomic nervous system.
If you have two parts of it, your sympathetic, or you heard it with your bite of flight mechanism,
and your parasympathetics, which are your collated, relaxedated detoxified, and your healing
part of the autonomics and coffee enemas are stimulated, that part of the autonomics.